as Don broke police Burst Into The
Village taking protesters by surprise
activists occupying the entrance to
lutsurat were pushed back
[Applause]
shame on you they shouted at police
those who didn't follow orders were
carried out with the police often using
Force to remove them
so what we're seeing here is that from
almost every state in Germany police is
being sent here for this eviction and
that really shows the priorities of the
state and the government people here who
are trying to defend our livelihoods who
are trying to to stop climate
destruction
that's where the priorities are to evict
those people and that's really absurd
and crazy
one by one they're being dragged out
making the village of Lutheran emptier
and emptier as we speak but this protest
that has been lasting for years is not
over yet
thousands of police officers were used
to clear the village which had been
occupied by activists for the past two
years
during the eviction Dina Hamid hid in
one of the houses she sees luzarat as a
symbol of Germany's failing climate
policies what we really want is to get
as many people here as possible because
we know if we are many we can still stop
the call from being burned so that's why
we're playing for time that's where
we'll be we will be as far as up as we
can go and then they will need some time
to take us down
but their time in the village is running
out while protesters showed some
acrobatic skills police have brought in
specialist Personnel to remove them from
roofs and three houses
The Showdown at the mine has become
particularly uncomfortable for the green
party whose Minister has been
responsible for keeping coal-fired
plants open he says the war in Ukraine
has delayed climate goals
I too believe that climate protection
and protests need symbols but the empty
settlement of lutherat where no one
lives anymore is in my view the wrong
symbol from 2030 normal call will be
used to produce electricity in the
rhineland's coal mines my political rock
is aimed at achieving similar deals
elsewhere in Germany
the activists have said that even after
the eviction their protests over the
Mind expansion will continue stepfast
and Al Jazeera in luzarap